bonjour via les lorrains on vous
retrouve à vienne au siège de l'aiea que
dit l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique
alors là j'en deviens de dire à
l'instant dans 28 qu'elle avait été
informée donc par l'ukraine de cette
perte d'alimentation à la centrale de
tchernobyl mais qu'elle ne voyait pas
après cet événement d'impact critique
sur la sécurité donc sur cet événement
lagence veut donc rassurante mais elle
avait par ailleurs indiqué quelques
heures plus tôt que la transmission à
distance des données des systèmes de
contrôle installés sur place avait été
coupé la jambe d'un tir éférence aux
caméras et aux autres outils placé dans
le cadre de sa mission de surveillance
du caractère pacifique des programmes
nucléaires dans le monde le site de
tchernobyl et on le rappelle contrôlé
par les russes depuis le début du
conflit et le directeur général de l'aïe
rappelle gros site est dit également
profondément préoccupé par la situation
difficile et stressante dans laquelle se
trouve le personnel de la centrale
nucléaire plus de 200 techniciens et
gardes sont bloqués sur le site travail
en 13 jours d'affilée sous surveillance
russe l'organisme a donc demandé à
moscou de les autoriser à effectuer des
rotations le repos et les horaires fixes
étant essentiels à la sécurité du site
et face à cette situation rappelle
grossi a plusieurs fois réitéré son
offre de se rendre sur le site ou
ailleurs pour obtenir de toutes les
parties un engagement cadors de la
sûreté et de la sécurité des centrales
nucléaires ukrainiennes on n'a pas
d'impact majeur sur la sécurité à
tchernobyl c'est ce que dit les yeux à
merci dans tout cas